here with reaction Louisiana Senator
John Kennedy Senator first
congratulations on your Victory uh we
didn't have to give it very much
attention to people of Louisiana know a
good thing when they see it uh
congratulations to you
um how important do you think this race
is and how do you see it unfolding
well a neutral Observer might point out
Sean that President Obama
came into Georgia for Miss Stacy Abrams
in her gubernatorial bid and it didn't
seem to help her very much but if I were
running senator warnock's campaign I
would certainly bring in President Obama
before I'd bring in President Biden
um as I've told you before I don't hate
anyone but at this juncture the Biden
Administration I think is best known
uh for its world-class vacuity
um according to the polls most Americans
wouldn't
wouldn't trust President Biden assault
the fries at McDonald's now as to
Georgia
um in a 50-50 Senate which we'll have of
Mr Walker is elected it will be much
easier much easier to beat back
the berserk wing of the Democratic Party
but it's not just about votes in the
Senate it's also about values in America
in my opinion uh Herschel Walker
understands that vetting people at the
border is not racist it's prudent
Herschel Walker understands that the
criminals are not the good guys they're
the bad guys
Herschel Walker understands that we need
to have an election day not an election
month
and Herschel Walker understands that
Arlington National Cemetery
contains 400 000 reasons why you should
stand your ass up for the national
anthem and that's really what this
election is all about and the final
point I'd make if if to the good people
of Georgia if nothing I have said has
persuaded you here's what I want you to
do
before you go to the polls
go grocery shopping
fill up your gas tank and pay your
electric bill and then ask yourself how
you ought to vote you know Senator I
cannot get over the mysterious
reluctance and resistance uh Democrats
have towards making any fundamental
changes when it comes to anything Biden
was asked well what are you going to do
differently after the midterms and his
answer was nothing okay so now we're
going to have what 45 percent increases
in areas in the country to heat their
homes this winter gas prices now
beginning their their rapid climb once
again he's not tapping into the
Strategic petroleum reserves uh we're
back to what we're going to give MBS
a free pass for the killing of Jamal
khashoggi and give them immunity does
that sound like a good idea to you
sounds like Joe's trying to still suck
up to OPEC and the Saudis and OPEC Plus
for for the lifeblood of our economy
when we have plenty of energy right here
at home
well these midterm elections were were
not an endorsement of President Biden
these elections were an endorsement of
divided government that's what the
American people want the polls about the
Red Wave were simply wrong I'm not sure
for a variety of reasons that the
American people can be polled right now
uh but it wasn't an endorsement of
President Biden uh not by a long shot it
was an endorsement of divided government
and I'm I'm going to keep getting up
every day and uh fighting for what I
think or or the values and the and how
to solve the problems that most
Americans moms and dads worry about when
they lie down to sleep at night and
can't I hope that President Biden will
work with us but I've seen no indication
that he will and and I can't think of
one problem in America today that the by
the administration is an answer to Sean
I wish I didn't have to say that but I
just can't no I can't think of it either
and you know suffering the poor the
middle class people on fixed income
items and I see things getting
dramatically worse before we even have a
shot at making them better Senator
Kennedy appreciate you being with us as
always thank you sir hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else